robe on a Star Wars story is almost here
yay I've gotten a lot of questions from
my casual fan friends about the who the
what the where if it and Ray why is this
happening and if you're feeling that way
it's okay I'm here to explain it to you
rope one is the first Star Wars spin-off
movie it stands alone from the prequel
trilogy from the original trilogy from
The Adventures of fit and ray it's
completely by itself the first thing
that you need to know is the timeline
when is this taking place okay so you
have the original trilogy that started
in nineteen seventy seven and then you
have the prequel trilogy that came out
after okay that's kind of confusing
rogue one takes place in between those
closer to episode for the original Star
Wars movie in 1977 so you know that
opening crawl text in Star Wars Episode
four that says rebel spies stole the
plans to the Death Star that's rogue one
that's the entire plot of rogue one
condensed into one sentence so yes we do
know the ending kind of of rogue one
which is interesting but what's exciting
is the unknown first of all we did not
know that this badass rebel spy named
Jane Eyre so was responsible for
stealing the plans to the death star
because she gets zero credit and we've
never hear about her again we don't hear
about a lot of these characters ever
again so it's kind of safe to assume
that a lot of them might not make it out
alive it's going to be very totally
different from the other Star Wars
movies and that's because this movie is
taking place at a time where the Jedi
were thought to be extinct so we're not
really focusing on any lightsabers were
more focusing on the rebels and the
x-wings and the pilots and the fighters
all that stuff it's gonna be more of
like a gritty kind of war movie when
Gareth Edwards the director was first
announced he compared it to a bunch of
war movies and my favorite quote of his
was when he said hey it's called Star
Wars it's also going to be the first
Star Wars movie without an opening crawl
the way Gareth Edwards and Kathleen
Kennedy explained it was they didn't
want to do an opening girl because it
was like too much inception if it's too
meta an opening crawl within an opening
crawl and then you could do another
movie off of that that's basically
everything that you must know about
rogue one now there's plenty of other
things that I can recommend to you so if
you want to talk about that hit me up on
Twitter and of course are you excited
the rogue one what are your thoughts let
us know if you see it in the comments
below anything you want to say to me to
us and of course hit subscribe there's
more videos like this they're really fun
watch them all have a good time